you had no money bad credit no
experience unemployed how much money
have you raised in the last 12 months
just shy of half a million there's this
hotel I've been looking at and we rung
them we secured it within 2 days even if
you don't get the planning it's going to
be worth about 1.2 and how much are you
buying it for 260 that's incredible one
thing about being poor and being rich
you're in a rut you feel like you can't
get out of that PO tell me about the pub
I'm paying 130 grand for the pub where
is it just down the road from the hotel
we're taking over this one town it's
almost like where the hell are you
finding these
[Music]
deals Dell thank you for coming on win
us on a Wednesday happy to be here so
when we met first what were you doing
financially how were you doing and what
was your job I was driving Lor's okay so
I was a class one Lorry driver I was
earning I went parttime to try and get
into property so I was working like
three days a week trying to get
investors for a little bite toet or
something but with no experience that's
harder like much harder it is hard yeah
especially when you're a lorry driver
and you've not got a track record yeah
exactly what were you making then what
was your salary just over a grand one
two a month yeah so were you did you
have a lot of money saved no nothing any
money saved no I was paying 950 quid a
month for childcare just to work damn
yeah yeah it was ridiculous how's that
work then I was still making a bit of
money damn yeah and now you're a
property millionaire yeah in 12 months
financially free high five yeah how does
it feel to have taken such a massive
U-turn financially from a lorry driver
making that kind of insane it's just
insane cuz people knew me for being you
know poor like I was just I was poor I
had loads of animals and my my little
girl and do you know what I mean like
everyone just knew yeah so um yeah it
it's it's mental and now I've got people
ringing me from my past saying how are
you doing what you doing like oh you
have to teach me and I'm like I can't
teach anyone don't come to me go to the
academy wow so what does it feel like
how does it feel do you have have to
pinch yourself yeah massively the main
name for me cuz I the Lorry job I lost
it just before I met you so I well s
technically unemployed when I met you
actually but I just lost it cuz my
daughter started going to school so I
was starting really early and I was
paying a million pound for her to go
into the nursery or whatever but they
started earlier so when she started
actual school I couldn't do the lores
anymore it just didn't work so then I
had a red do poker up my bum to earn
some money yeah my brother I've got two
brothers right one of them now works
with me but the middle one he kept
mentioning you Samuel this Samuel that
who else Samuel I looked you up and then
I you crash courses so I was like right
it's his birthday I paid two quid and
they took him as a surprise down to see
you by the end of the day I was signing
up to the academy and he never joined
wow what does he think now of your
journey I'm not sure have you spoke to
him yeah last thing he said to my mother
was how much did she even earn like he
he skeptical you mean yeah I think he's
still skeptical yeah why do you think
that is cu he knew me before yeah I was
poor I was poor for ages well Jesus says
that Jesus says a prophet has no honor
in his hometown yeah famili arity
breathes contempt people are familiar
with you whereas when you're on the
academy you've suddenly got all these
people got a fresh start no one knows
your P exactly knows no one cares you're
just in property yeah so family and that
I never even bothered I didn't never ask
them for investment because I knew they
wouldn't based on the fact that how much
money have you raised in the last 12
months just shy of half a million just
shy of half a million and that's money
in the bank yeah damn so you are an
expert at raising Finance I'm getting
better at it as it yeah but how though
I'm not being funny but when you got no
Tru record in property you're not like
super professional and you're a lorry
driver how are you able to raise so much
tangible cash what are you doing so what
the first guy that I ever got to invest
in me was through a Facebook post so I
kept posting in this group different
deals and need this much for that much
they give you fixed percent return blah
blah blah and he said that I've ignored
so many of those posts he said but for
some reason I just got drawn to the last
one you put so we ended up getting and
loads of people used to contact me about
the post but never nothing ever came of
it aart from him yeah so the deal that
he invested in fell through and then I
asked him if we could repurpose it into
essays cuz I'd met you at that point um
and that's what we did so I put it into
the first couple of essays and uh went
from there and he actually that guy now
guarantors me on everything because he
needed to at the beginning and we've
bought a property together since wow and
where is it that's all of them South
Wales everything I've bought is in South
Wales right and today is your birthday
congrats happy birthday you just had a
you told me you just secured a big deal
recently which I don't even know about
because it's brand new talk to me about
that okay so you know we went to Uganda
yes I met a lovely lady there that we
bonded with really well Hannah yeah
Hannah B yeah course so we said we were
going to do something together I she's
smart by the way I know she's a smart
cookie very very successful property
investor she's a property millionaire
herself and she's a developer and yeah
so she was telling me she'd just done
the nine bed HMO everything like that
and I said I was I've bought a pub of
either I'm converting into a 15 bed HMO
so we we bonded over that we're doing a
similar thing she's just much further
ahead than me yeah so we were talking
about investing together in this uh 10
bed HMO well the deal got sold to
somebody else somebody else got it right
they offered more than us but they had a
chain so I thought we were still going
to get it it was what it was annoying
but anyway so then I said to her look
there's this hotel I've been looking at
I like really want to buy it I was like
next thing you know it came up and we
rung them and we we secured it within
two days so we're buying a hotel what
where is it South Wales yeah so talk to
me about this hotel then uh so it I saw
an auction house sign on it so I rang
the auction house and they said look no
sold back in 2020 somebody must have
left the sign up and I was like that's a
shame they haven't done anything with it
yeah I was like what's happening so I
was going to track them down and then
next thing you know it came up and my
brother sent it to me he keeps on top of
that stuff now because I'm doing the BRS
yeah yeah so he he sent me the link and
I was like oh it's finally it's come so
they what they've been doing is getting
planning that's what they've done so
they got the planning on it to turn it
into eight apartments and a commercial
unit at the bottom right so me and
Hannah we talked it through the numbers
work with that it's going to be worth
1.2 just with that but we're going to go
back to planning they wanted us to
demolish a coach house which is outside
mhm that could be more flats and there's
a massive demand for one bed Flats in
area so we're going to contest by doing
that like saying look we're providing
more housing blah blah yeah yeah um and
also the commercial unit it's
unnecessary we if you don't get the plan
in it's going to be worth about 1.2 how
much are you buying it for 260 260
Grand jeez I know but the referb on that
just the flats alone would be about 400
just over but still if it's worth 1.2 at
the end that's incredible I know so I
think one of the reasons you've been so
successful I think number one is I think
you are courageous definitely and you
just th I mean the fact that you even
joined the academy how did you afford to
join the academy my my initial investor
you got an investment yeah yeah so I pay
him a fix percentage return on the money
how much interest I pay 12% on that
that's a ballsy move it would have been
more for me if I'd have done it as a
loan cuz my credit weren't great when I
started so you join the academy you had
no money bad credit no experience no job
unemployed a lot of people would have
said that me taking you on was almost um
a risk because if you'd have been
unsuccessful it would been oh why did
you take this lady's money it's very
difficult for me because how do you
decide who to have because you know we
go through a rigorous interview process
yeah yeah so christed mine but
realistically speaking I've done so do
you know Peter Jones Dragon Den yeah I
went to his Academy when I was like 19
okay I've always been business minded I
felt I did really well in that year like
we did a hypothetical pitch for
investment and they gave it the money to
me nice it was it wasn't supposed to be
an actual invest you were 19 yeah so it
went really really well but then for me
it was either business or animals and I
made the conscious choice to go with the
animals you don't make much money it's a
lifestyle choice but I've done different
companies AC like I've sold products on
Amazon I've done loads of different
companies that have paid for me to
travel abroad to work with animals right
so well I think that's the thing cuz I
remember you at the I think it was the
deal selling Master Class yeah um and I
remember thinking you know what this
lady's n she she's got passion she's
energy and even though you didn't have
super property or business experience
you got a decent business brain yeah
yeah um but it's incredible to how where
you've gone I think some people they're
smart and they're poor yeah and they're
poor not because the fact that they're
not hardworking it's not because they're
not smart they're in the wrong industry
and I think before financially you in
the wrong industry yeah yeah definitely
like because you do one thing about
being and being rich now I know the
difference like you're in a rut that
that you feel like you can't get out of
that pom if you know what I mean I had
nothing to lose so I knew I could give
it my all whereas like my brother for
instance he might have struggled to do
that because he had a family to pay for
whereas I only had one kid to pay you
like my credit's already
screwed where can it go from there only
up so I had nothing to lose and I got no
money I got no job and that's dangerous
in terms of being dangerous to the
market like that that that's a
powerfully dangerous position to be in
because when you got nothing to lose and
that's why so many kids are successful
teenagers 17 18 they just fly and then
you got like some 50-year-old who's got
you know two cars a corporate job four
week holiday year really scared yeah
they are and scared money don't make
money yeah yeah my mom for instance she
backs us she's behind us and all of that
stuff but she's still you can feel the
hesitancy she's scared about what we're
doing all the time yeah but she still
backs us she still thinks it's great and
everything but that that that hesitancy
is still there because they've been
trained to just get a job job get your
mortgage paid yeah die so you've bought
a bunch of houses yeah and a hotel yeah
and a pub and a pub it's almost like
real life Monopoly yeah because I I need
the investors right so I need to be able
to give them a big chunk back I don't
think 10 12% does it anymore right so I
offer 25% but there to do that I need to
have big things with massive profits
they get theirs even if I I will still
make money off all of them but even if I
didn't make any money off of them on the
refinance I'd still then own the asset
and have the cash flow so that's that's
my thinking on it are they getting
Security on on on the loans are they
getting like a charge person no they're
getting personal guarantees from me so
what would happen if the deal wen't
really sour and you couldn't pay the
investor back we we'd have to sell one
of the assets or something you'd have to
sell them yeah from the Investor's
perspective it is risk there is risk but
but there's also High reward yeah yeah
big returns because you're not giving
them 5% you're giving them a lot more so
it's high risk High rewards um I guess
as long as the investor um understands
that risk yeah and as long as and then
the investors presumably able to come
down see the project
involved in it no one's done that yet
but they can have they not yeah no no
one they're all off the academy no I
think the academy people trust the
academy people as well so there is that
level of and also you're covered you've
got redress yep so if if there was a
deal to go wrong yeah yeah you'd be
covered and then they'd be able to
report you we've got insurance as well
Insurance mediation and things like that
how are you getting these investors to
actually sign on the dotted line I say
what we're offering sometimes it's 25%
sometimes 25% plus 5% of the cash flow
for two years yeah just to keep people
board and people people have been really
receptive people say they're struggling
to get raised Finance all the time and
just keep putting it out there people
start understanding and I keep getting
advised to do stuff on Instagram a lot
yeah since I've been doing that I was I
went to the academy party last week
people knew my name before it even said
anything and it was crazy to me like it
was and I thought well that's that's
just cuz I up my Instagram game a bit
but also you're dealing with I think
it's important as well when you're
raising Finance it's important to be
dealing with smart people yeah because
you don't want to be taking 50 Grand off
of your nan or your auntie who doesn't
know the risk doesn't understand but
people like Hannah Bowden she's a
property developer yeah exactly so if
she's seen this hotel and what what's
the deal then what's the business
structure of that hotel that you're
buying we've we've set up a company
together yeah um we're still I because
it's only happened a couple of days ago
so we're still eyeing out the details on
that but um funnny enough have you seen
the Uganda stuff the videos and things
I've seen some of it the kids sung a
song for us and it was wellcome we've
called the company well come limited cuz
it doesn't really matter what you call
it does it there's no advertising to be
done yeah exactly I said we need to do
something Uganda related cuz that's
where we met right so we went with that
how was Uganda insane it was so
overwhelming so humbling like we we went
to seven schools we saw all the
different schools went to the hospital
that you've already started building
that that ward in it's so humbling like
I I don't even know how to say it like
as soon as I got back my kid was like I
want more chocolate and I was like No
And you donated as well you donated
£5,000 which we really appreciate yeah
yeah going towards the building of the
hospital yeah that's it and Tony's been
asking us what we think the next project
should be and stuff like that it's been
it's been incredible to be part of it to
be part of the process and to to help
help them so you're buying this hotel
with Hannah yeah the pub is all me is
all you tell me about the pub so the pub
I'm paying peanuts for the pub I'm
paying 130 grand for the pub yeah
including that and where where is it
South Wales same just down the road from
a hotel taking over this one town what's
the town called it's it's called My Stig
to talk to me about the pup you bought
it for 130 what are the figures 130 so
I've done the commercial valuation with
Simon Olson it's coming out at 686 and
how much you having to spend on it 150
so you're buying it for 130 spending 150
on it so all in you're talking about 280
yeah and then the end valuation
commercial valuation is that based on
the rent that's based on the annual rent
of all the rooms yeah minus your
expenses times 100 I think that's the
calculation in it yeah so that's why I
keep running through it with Simon cuz I
just say I just need to check that this
is correct and this is stuff that very
difficult to find online if you go on
the internet and you and you search how
to work out commercial valuation stuff
like there's very little information on
it so it's important to have experts
that you can speak to yeah exactly so
you raised the money to put into the pub
yes so we didn't need that much we've
got 100% development Finance so that's
that c really yeah from from who from an
amazing bridging broker so he sorted us
out with the property that I just bought
with the land yeah so because he's dealt
with us already he knows he can get me
100% development Finance so you're
getting 100% development Finance from A
lender a lenda yeah wow yeah and the
development font is going to be about
150 150 Grand they're going to give you
the entire amount yeah but so we need to
we do need the funds to kick it off so
the first month it's all on a scheduled
plan is the first month we need so we
still need that money to just kick that
off but that's only 2030 Grand and
obviously we're buying the pub for 130 I
think the the deposit on that is about
32 Grand wow so we only needed about 60
grand total so you bought it with a
mortgage no with the bridge again hang
on a minute you bought the pub yeah for
130 mhm you own needed to put down 30%
uh 25% so you only put 30 grand yeah 32
Grand so you bought a pub for 30 grand
sounds great where did you get the 30
grand from an
investor so you put in nothing so you
borrowed 30 grand from an investor then
you got the rest on a bridge y now
people will say bridging's really risky
well hang on a minute number one a
bridge will only loan money on a deal
where they know the deal has got a lot
of juice in it it needs a lot of cushion
otherwise they won't lend so I'm quite
comforted in knowing the fact that a
bridging company has loaned you not only
the purchase but also 100% of the
development because they'll do a lot of
due diligence before they loan yeah
they'll have been out surveys so they
obviously think it's a banger do you
know who the lender is no the last one I
used was Castle trust with the same
bridging guy so I'm wondering if he's
probably done it with the same people
but you got your which broker are you
using uh fin space they're in London you
know him uh no I don't actually he's a
brilliant guy so I've got a brilliant
mortgage broker that I was using before
right but and he does
but he's this guy this new this guy in
fin space he if if there's a problem or
something comes up he'll figure a way to
fix it you know what I mean he's very
outboxing you that you need Sol like
that accounts like that solic are the
only thing I could do with help with
right I can't find a good quick solic
anywhere well good and quick don't go
together no that's the thing like they
don't with solic they're either good or
they're quick okay they can be good and
quick but then they're very expensive
yeah yeah but we'll talk about that so
so you're putting in 30 grand then
you're borrowing the entirety on
development finance and bridging loan
but then you're going to refinance yeah
and the new value you're thinking is
somewhere around 600 Grand over 686
which means that you'll pull out all the
money you'll pay back the bridging
company you'll pay about the development
Finance you'll pay about the investor
you'll pay them all their interest and
you'll be left with a free Pub yeah well
not even a pub because you'll there'll
be profit there as well damn that's
incredible all right golden question
then is where the hell are you finding
these deals just going out like once I'd
seen the pub so once the pub had come up
and the numbers were so incredible I
just started looking for commercial
premises yeah so deliber so I just
deliberately went that route so there's
our old childhood doctor surgeries up
for S I want to buy it it's a long it's
two stories long Corridor loads of rooms
off it in a car park perfect HMO so it's
already built to be a HMO it's in the
middle of town the best part one of the
best parts of town as well so I'm just
waiting for that cuz they're struggling
to relocate at the minute right so I'm
I'm on a list waiting for that to so
you're just aggressively going out
viewing stuff dealing with agents
commercial commercial agents yeah but
actually I keep sending my brother out I
bought my brother on board but he
doesn't know what I know but I'm
teaching him as we go so he does all the
viewings down and stuff like that you've
been training for a year yeah and I'm
dealing with all the paper bridging is
so much paperwork as you say they do
diligence and the the last one I bought
with the land that took forever to get
across the line we had to change company
structure we had to do loads of stuff
did you ever go to university or
anything yeah what did you study animal
biology biology yeah do you think that
the training courses on the
is better and more detailed and richer
in knowledge than the university I'll
tell you something which is going to
blow your mind because it blew my mind
at the time I'm paid a lot of money to
go to university I got pulled aside by
one of the teachers and told that I was
asking too many questions I said I'm
paying you to ask questions did they
they said that yeah I was upset I was a
bit like taken back I was like what's
what's the point then how much did you
pay to go to youa about 9 and half in it
per per term or per year per year how
many years did you go three so you spent
about 30 grand and you were told after
paying 30 grand that you're asking too
many questions but then on the academy
not only is the content so rich and
everyone that's been to University says
this is so much better yeah in terms of
the detail and everything but also you
can book on limited mentoring and and we
say to un we're like book as many as you
want keep booking them keep booking them
keep asking questions how's it been on
the academy how have you found the
learning element of it absolutely
incredible so all the trainings I did
all my training like Bam Bam Bam one a
month like I just got them all done and
I was gutted when i' finished yeah
because I was away from the environment
but I've asked if I can crew now cuz I
want to come back because I get to
refresh on the knowledge but I also get
to help others like with their Journey
now as they start yeah but it's
incredible I wouldn't be anywhere near
where I am if it wasn't for the Academy
like I needed that well it's not just
the information either it's the people
yeah it is it's everyone the whole team
even the people crewing they're all old
Academy members and things like that
it's just insane and the knowledge as
you say the knowledge you said a key
couple of things that have stuck with me
and I held on to them so like your net
worth is your net worth yeah oh well
yeah that but also you explained how it
it's calculated oh your net worth
because it's not actually your net worth
your net worth is your network is is
true true but that's not how you
calculate it no no so I was so as soon
as you said that I was focusing on the
essay I just needed to get my cash flow
going so I was covering myself my
daughter I was going to ask you that you
got the houses and you bought Pub and
hotel and all that where's your actual
money coming from now the I went
straight for essays I never dealt with I
didn't bother with deal selling straight
off the bat I just went for the essays
cuz it was consistent right it's quick
cash but consistent cash how many essay
do you have four so you got four service
accommodation units yeah apartments or
houses Apartments how did you fund them
JVS I got four JVS who are all now like
good friends of mine and wow yeah are
they happy are they yeah yeah cuz
they're making money yeah how much do
the four properties make on average
about a grand grand and a half a month
each so about sort of five six grand
yeah and then but they get so I give my
investors 75% until they get their
initial investment back out yeah so I'm
only getting 25% initially right for do
all the work yeah but again I've hired
someone on my sa business now so she
does my cash flow she does all my but if
you want to putting any money in who
cares yeah exact so how much have you
paid them off now not quite almost no no
yeah because it was all the beginning of
this year wasn't it so it's about 8 to
10 months give or take we nearly there
so that's kind of like replaced your
Lori driving in so to speak I didn't
need that much and a bit more I've been
living a different life because of it
yeah you know what I mean I I've got a
bit more my kid gets whatever she wants
now I got to stop doing that but because
it is changing but but yeah cuz I got
more money I wanted to spoiler and now
and you're just playing real life
Monopoly buying pubs hotels houses crazy
don't stop when you pass Cod so so what
would you tell somebody that was in your
situation a year and a half ago what
would you say to somebody that had no
money bad credit was working their ass
off or even worse unemployed and had a
Caden and wanted to have this dream life
of buying hotels and pubs and houses and
Financial Freedom what advice would you
give them just join the academy
there's nothing else you can do like if
you haven't got the money which you
probably won't cuz you're unemployed
like me just just find it wow beg borrow
and steal get the money
like just just get the money come to the
account come to the pound crash course
you might meet someone there you can get
the money off give them a fixed
return that's what I'd say but you've
got to have the confidence in yourself I
always knew I wanted to be in business I
always knew I didn't want to work for
someone else to make them Rich one of
the the Lorry company I work for they
used to announce their profits we're all
getting 11 quid an hour they used to
drive me mad so I've always been of that
mindset I think you need the right
mindset and then go to the academy yeah
yeah yeah I definitely think coming to a
one pound crash course is a good start
yeah yeah it all starts at the crash
course I'll leave a link in the
description people can can can can book
on for a pound I'll leave your Instagram
and stuff as well I want to reach out to
you I just want to say I'm really proud
of you and keep up the good work and
happy birthday thank you very much I'll
keep you posted on the on the hotel do
it well done